[Music]
so welcome to philosophers in the midst
of History
um this has been going on since 2016
with a little break due to covid
quarterly series every year we do an
ancient philosopher a medieval
philosopher and early modern and then a
later modern philosopher and this time
around for the later modern philosopher
I picked somebody who I Shadow I
probably should have talked about a long
time ago since I did my dissertation on
him or he's blown down I guess I just
you know thought other people might be
more attractive or interesting but you
know it was it was fun to go back to his
his thought which I've never completely
left and he's kind of a you could say an
undervalued stock right not a lot of
people know about them there's a lot of
really interesting stuff in his his work
and he lived through some very
interesting times for quite a long time
you he died in 1949 you know after the
world had been through all these
upheavals
um and he had a massive impact even
after his his death some people have
called him the philosopher of Vatican II
in part because different strains of his
influence lead to the second Vatican
Council and what goes on in it he's not
that that much read today and and it's
in part
because of something that I think I may
have mentioned in in previous sessions
sometimes there's like a vicious cycle
that goes on where
um a philosopher hasn't been translated
that much in his case from French into
English and because of that people who
are teaching or studying philosophy
assume that well if it was important it
would have been translated and so we're
not going to pay attention to it and
that means there's less interest in
producing new translations which uh just
kind of reinforces itself as as a cycle
I have actually translated some of
blondell's work in my 2011 book
um reason fulfilled by Revelation the
1930s Christian philosophy debates in
France there were four pieces that I I
translated for that I I wanted to
translate five but actually the Society
detoured philosophic
wouldn't allow me to publish one of them
there's there's a little story there
that we can talk about later on
um his his most well-known book is Axion
1893.
um this is the Oliver blah translation
and I actually had a correspondence with
all about blasette and asked him why he
um translated this given that there was
already a translation out there and he
was at Boston College for for a very
long time he died just just recently and
he said well the previous translation I
was using it to teach in class and it
was so bad I kept on having to correct
it to my students and so I thought well
what the hell I'll just I'll just
translate it myself and you can tell you
know I mean this is kind of a at home
right it's not a short little work
um I mentioned that uh I wrote my
dissertation on Blondell so I'm going to
tell a little bit of personal story
before we we jump into talking about him
just because it might be of some
interest so
I didn't have any intention of studying
this guy originally and I haven't even
heard of him but I was
um going to satisfy a requirement for my
Graduate Studies of translating a work
from French
and you could either like take a
translation class you know just for for
like
non-specialists or you could take a test
where they would like throw something at
you and have you translate it or you
could translate an article on your own
and so my mentor at the time was a guy
who kind of specialized in Holocaust
studies so I was you know I found a
piece that was kind of recent from
French about something having to do with
the Holocaust and I was like hey how
about I do this and he poked his head
into my office and he's like ah don't
don't bother with crap you know why
don't you translate something that needs
translating somebody who's been ignored
and neglected Marie's blowned out for
instance
and I thought oh okay
I better go and check this guy out so I
went to the library fortunately at that
time Southern Illinois University for a
uh you know sort of second-tier state
school had an amazing research Library
they had like all of Blondell stuff
available there in French and I I got
this uh I got this volume the the
primary key the first writings of
Maurice Blondell right and I started
reading through it and I was like oh
this is pretty cool stuff you know I
should translate this and then uh this
is you know there's there's a moral to
this story I started translating it so
I'd sit at my computer and
um you know I'd I'd have the book in
front of me and I'd you know puzzle over
how to translate this or translate that
and I got like 100 Pages done and then I
found out that somebody else had already
translated those writings and they
didn't need to be translated and I knew
that some had been translated already
namely the ones that wound up in this
volume the letter on apologetics in
history and Dogma but I was translating
the idealist illusion and an elementary
logic of the moral life turns out this
this uh Irish philosopher long had
already brought out a book and I just
didn't know about it so you know all
that effort kind of wasted but it got me
really interested in bloomedell and
um I kept reading them kept you know
thinking about him
I did a independent study with my mentor
for which by the way uh he never gave me
a great
um it's a good thing that I took extra
classes in graduate school because
otherwise I would have been you know in
some trouble
um he never he never uh he assigned me
an incomplete and then never assigned a
grade and then he retired and that was
that
so long story short I'm into Blondell
I'm also very much into
um uh Hegel somebody who we've talked
about before uh in the past and I was
going to write my dissertation on the
two different philosophers and do like a
compare contrast how do you get from
this guy to this guy Blondell is often
called the Catholic Hegel the French
Hagel because they've got a lot of
similarities in the way that they
approach things
and um my committee
you know what happens when you're going
to write a dissertation you first you do
a lot of other stuff you pass these
tests or things like that then you write
a prospectus and then in the prospectus
you're saying it's like a big promise or
you know I'm gonna do this this this and
this and then the committee gets
together and they're like well we don't
want you to do this we want you to do
this instead and they're in charge so
you kind of got to go with what they say
and their ruling was we think that's too
much for you to tackle
um writing about Hegel is already tough
you seem really into blown down why
don't you just write your dissertation
you know and there is like no uh
attention at all to like would this help
me get a job or something
um and I actually did have a guy later
on down the line at a place that I was
working he said nobody's ever going to
hire you to teach blown down you know uh
career-wise it wasn't the greatest move
but I I really enjoyed it and so I ended
up
um drawing on his unpublished or not
unpublished untranslated French works
and writing this big sprawling 350 page
dissertation that I've never published
um just cannibalize bits and pieces of
that's now actually in an ancient format
Word Perfect some of you may remember
that
um and I could convert it to word
possibly but there's all these you know
French
um diacritics right in it and all those
codes will get screwed up so I've never
bothered with that and I just kind of
moved on
but
um I had this this uh this uh British
pal of mine who said you should do some
translation uh blown down and I said
well I already tried that you know uh
and he said no no there's other things
that you should translate instead
you know the stuff from the Christian
philosophy debates in the 1930s and so
you know he sent me some some of the
photocopies of that and I started
digging into that and I this is a whole
different topic I eventually realized
that the English literature the English
language literature on the debates had
had shrunk it down to this tiny little
thing but it was actually a massive set
of debates that involved about 50
different people from 1931 to 1936 and
so I decided to translate some of them
and there's a lot of other people in
this book as well as well as a long
historical introduction and index and
stuff like that so it's not it's not all
translation but I thought you know
Blondell could use
um
you know getting out there unfortunately
this book which was intended to be like
a get people into the the study of stuff
Catholic University of America press
priced it too high so uh libraries
bought it a few Scholars bought it not
too many other people bought it if you
praise a book about 50 bucks generally
nobody's gonna buy it so you know that's
that's that so that's enough like
personal stuff
um
Blondell uh you've got this lengthy
timeline that I created with um what's
going on in his life and then what was
happening largely in France uh or French
matters and you notice he lived a long
long time born in 1861.
um so you know what's going on around
around that time uh he's born before the
first Vatican Council he's born shortly
before France is going to engage in some
more adventurism invading Mexico for
example and
um he's born in Dijon he is not somebody
from the Paris you could say
Intelligentsia or Elite or anything like
that he's from the provinces he's he's
not an ordinary guy he's from a
Bourgeois family but um these you know
in France uh even all all the way up to
today things are very very centralized
with Paris being like the center of the
universe I remember one time I I won't
say which famous philosopher this was
but I I was having lunch because he came
down to our school and I asked him
mistakenly well where in France are you
from and he looked at me like I was an
idiot
Paris where else you know like
everything important happens in Paris so
he's born out in the provinces and he's
born in a tumultuous time and he um his
family sends him to religious primary
school and that was at that time a
political move because the French third
Republic was very very anti-clerical
very anti-catholic that was seen as like
a black mark against him as a kid he
learns to read and write rather
reluctantly he's not super into that
that sort of stuff and then he enters
this secular lyceum in Dijon and he he
starts getting a classical education he
learns Greek and Latin he learns some
German doesn't really learn English
um that wasn't considered a high
priority at the time the way it would be
in the present and you know all sorts of
other things history some some science
mathematics and all of that
um by that time we see that the Frank
oppression War has happened and this is
a massive upheaval right because before
that the French were kind of the the
butt kickers right you had Napoleon and
it took like everybody lining up against
him to to bring him down and you know
they they try to shave France down a bit
but France is still a massively strong
country so for the prussians to come in
after they've already like you know
defeated Denmark and Austria and just
like knock the crap out of the French uh
in a big surprise uh it was you know it
was kind of a
a shock it led to the dissolution of the
government Napoleon III uh you know you
know it's the end of the Second Empire
and the end of his Reign
um the Paris commune forums and that is
repressed by the the Army
um
and so there's a lot going on
particularly in Paris meanwhile you know
Blondell is going along with his life
you know 13 years old he makes his first
communion he actually at that time there
was like a tradition for making your
first communion that you would pick a
brother uh somebody who you're going to
be connected with and he chooses a
chimney sweep this kid who's already
working and dirty as hell you know his
name is Augustine and he chooses him as
his brother his family's conflicted
about that but you know he's proceeding
along this this kind of a life where
he's taking religion quite seriously he
gets a bachelor of letters in rhetoric
from the lyceum Dijon then earns a
bachelor of letters in philosophy and
then he starts as a good dutiful you
know not quite boy anymore but young
adult he's going to study law like his
parents want him to and he gets drawn
off into philosophy which which is his
his true love and then he makes a a
really interesting fateful decision
he considers
um the possibility of a Priestly
vocation and there's letters I mean
there's letters about just about
everything with this guy because he
wrote tons and tons of letters that were
actually preserved
um and there's there's um some
Reflections on his part about why he
didn't become a priest
he decided instead of becoming a priest
he thought that he could follow what he
called a lay apostolate meaning doing
um you know a vocation within the world
and he would do so in philosophy and you
know with the current stature of
philosophy you might say well why did he
pick something that nobody pays
attention to anymore well at that time
they did pay attention to philosophy it
still had a lot more cultural cachet and
it was viewed as like this Capstone of
the sciences and very important for a
number of different reasons and he
thinks I'm going to
I'm gonna go to the Eco normal in Paris
and I'm going to study with the best
secular Minds there are
and I'm going to like bring Christianity
and philosophy into some sort of
fruitful contact with each other and
that's really the story of his his
entire career and I'm going to do so in
a way that will be faithful to
Christianity but will also be faithful
to philosophy there won't be any like
we're going to take Christianity and
like shove it down the Philosopher's
throats and you know superimpose it on
that there's not also going to not going
to be any like rationalization of
Christianity where we say well the
philosophy says this so so much the
worst for Christianity it's going to be
dialectical they're going to both
communicate with each other and they're
going to do so through my studies
through my mind and my my engagements
and so um he goes there and he studies
with this guy Leon uh uh uh Ole La prune
and Emil butro
um both of his professors who are kind
of sympathetic to what he's doing
because a lot of professors do not like
what he's doing at all you know they
view him as smuggling Christianity and
even worse Catholicism into
philosophical studies where it's got no
place whatsoever
um and he meets this guy Victor delbow
who he's he becomes very good friends
with who's a historian of philosophy
um Blondell fails the first couple times
that he takes the aggregation that is a
sort of like set of essay tests that you
need to take if you want to be
authorized to teach
and and not just teach like in the
University but even in like the junior
colleges and stuff like that
so he fails the first couple times and
he you know he keeps coming back he does
Teach as a substitute for a little while
at this Lisa and Shoma and then finally
passes his his aggregation examinations
and then he's appointed professor of
philosophy now that sounds very nice
being professor of philosophy but that
was the sort of title that would vary
depending on where you were teaching
so it's not like being professor of
philosophy at the sore button or being
professor of philosophy at the a Cole
nor mall he is teaching at another Lee
say in
um Ike's
and
um
you know it's not a bad gig for him he's
uh he has to overcome a bit of shyness
with the students as a matter of fact
there's a really great story that's told
about him he was very young looking
right and so
um they know that they're getting a new
teacher new professor and he's out there
like you know bsing around with the kids
with the the boys and
um young men really and um they're all
like well I wonder who this guy is and
what is he going to be like is he a jerk
is he a cool guy you know and then uh
they're all shuffling into class and
then he walks up to the front and he's
like all right let's start studying
philosophy and they're like holy crap
it's this guy that we're playing soccer
with just a couple minutes ago and and
shooting the breeze with good thing we
didn't say anything you know bad about
him or anything like that and uh you
know he uh he winds up at that point in
time he's got to start working on his
dissertation in France at that time you
actually wrote two dissertations you
wrote One dissertation in French and
that that'll become this laxiano 1893
translated into English I should mention
too why do I have two copies so when I
defended my dissertation my uh co-chair
because my mentor by then had retired so
he could only be co-chair uh the other
one who is still working there who's
still down there in Southern Illinois
came up to me and he's like
got a present for you here you go so the
you know he had a copy laying around
um and so I was like oh this is really
awesome now I finally got a copy for
myself I don't have to use the library
one but so he's working on Axiom 1893
and he also wrote a Latin dissertation
on leibniz so you know the Latin one
goes along swimmingly not a problem you
know everybody's like yeah this is
really great work it's on what he calls
the vinculum substantially the the
substantial link uh between uh various
different things uh it's I mean the
Latin title if you want to know is De
vinculos substantia
composite
you know very nice little thing not too
many people read it I've never read it
myself
um
doesn't appear to have made a big splash
or anything like that
axio 1893 was probably one of the most
controversial dissertations published in
that era
in part because what he's doing to begin
with he I'll say just a few things so
one of the things that he's doing it's
called oxia 1983 so he's focusing on
action the category of action Human
Action Praxis right and he's focusing
very heavily on an analysis of how the
will works and it's dialectical so it
starts at the like the lowest levels and
then builds up you know and everything
is in this very complex you could call
it system that he's elaborating and it
has to be not a rigid system but one
that's flexible enough to extend to
human Affairs so it's very much like
hegel's phenomenology of spirit which is
much harder to read Because Blondell is
not the greatest writer but he's a lot
more clear than Hegel is
in the fifth part of action
there is this entire discussion of
um
religion
Blondell thought
that you cannot avoid what at the time
was called the religious problem namely
um you know as we're moving into the
from the uh
the enlightenment into the 19th century
an era of Science and positivism and all
sorts of you know problems within the
church and things like that and we're
moving into the new century is all this
religious stuff just kind of BS or a
waste of time is it something we are
going to leave behind as human beings
should we get rid of the idea of the
supernatural you know what's what's the
going on there that's happening on the
secular side right and philosophy is
mostly there
the Catholic church is also going
through an intellectual Renaissance at
that time
attorney potris is published in 1879 by
Leo the 13th which is a calling for a
Revival of the study of Saint Thomas and
of Scholastic writers
that leads to new institutions being
formed like luvan in Belgium all sorts
of houses of studies all over the place
and there's there's conflict between
secular philosophers and in France
largely Catholic philosophers there were
a few reformed Protestants as well and
and things like this are happening in
Germany and they're happening in Italy
and they're happening to a different in
a different way in England
um Leo the 13th is also going to publish
another massively important encyclical
during his lifetime called the rayroom
Navarro on new things this is a
articulation of of Catholic social
theory
um you know sort of in the face of all
these different movements that are going
on thinking about
Labor capitalism it's arguing for giving
the job you know just wages uh it says
that you can have trade unions and
things like that it's also like arguing
against
communism and socialism and it's
articulating a whole new way of seeing
things so there's a lot going on within
Catholic intellectual life and Blondell
is sort of like riding this Crest so the
question is where does he belong does he
belong in the secular Academy
well you know when you get to part five
of this book and he's telling you that
there is the one thing necessary and
that's that's God there's actually a
chapter title the one thing necessary
right and that everybody has to make an
option they have to decide between uh
one one way of orienting their life or
another so his dissertation defense went
on like for hours
and you know if you've ever been in a
dissertation defense
it's kind of a scary situation right did
you do a dissertation defense so you
know one of the things that happens I
don't know if this happened to you but
you can have prepared as much as you
like and then they say okay we've heard
your thing you know you've defended your
thing now would you please leave the
room and so like you know you go out and
you're in the hallway and they're
conferring and you know they might keep
you out there for half an hour or
something and then they bring you back
in and usually they're like
congratulations Dr so and so you know
but you don't know
right and in blondell's case a lot of
the people were really ready to argue
they're like this this is great up to
chapter four part four we don't like
this other stuff
and
um you know eventually he he's passed
but you can tell that it leaves a stain
because they won't give him a job
in France at the time there was a
minister of education and then you know
all these bureaucrats under him
and uh Blondell was denied a teaching
position because it was viewed that he
was suspect uh he'd smuggled in religion
in by the back door
um now you know shortly after he defends
his dissertation two really important
things happen one personal for Blondell
one for France itself
he meets uh Rose uh Royer meets her
falls in love with her she falls in love
with him they're married within months
um she will be his his only wife in the
course of his life unfortunately she
will die kind of young
um compared to him but they have a
really wonderful life together at the
same time the Dreyfus Affair is
happening
so you know we often learn about this
like in history books oh you know the
Dreyfus Affair in France
this was something that
factionalized France
just as much as
recent any recent event that we can
think of you know you think of
um the rise of the Tea Party and
um you know the Trump presidency and the
polarization involved in that
the Dreyfus Affair was like that
different institutions are lining up for
and against racist Dreyfus was a Jewish
French military officer gets accused of
being a spy he's not actually the Spy it
turns out they figure out who the the
real spy is a couple years later he gets
sent to prison
um and then you know Zola writes this
jacuzz you know saying basically look at
this Kangaroo Court nonsense that's
going on and it brings a whole bunch of
people in on all sides of French society
and it's going to lead
ultimately not just to these fractures
but to the rise of
um
what will ultimately be fascism in
France
there is a proto-fascist organization
that gets started
um called oxyon Francis and they're
going to be one of the main enemies of
everybody on the left and even people
who are kind of in the middle like
Blondell
um It's associated you know at first
with these two guys Maurice pujo and
Aria Bourgeois but then you get this guy
charl Mora and Mariah is a writer he's a
atheist who thinks that Catholicism
could be a really useful tool
um he's against uh you know anybody on
the left he's also against Jews he's
also against
um uh migrant workers you know they were
called the metis at that time in in
France and they've got a newspaper
they've got a youth group The you know
the common law
they they form what are arguably the
first Stormtroopers
um and they start beating the crap out
of people and and you know they're on a
broad front and a lot of Catholic
intellectuals
um lined up with with [ __ ] one of them
uh who eventually left after auction
Frances was finally condemned was uh
Jacques Marathon
who uh was you know uh leading Catholic
thinker at the time uh Blondell himself
is getting involved in all of this this
ferment and one thing you can say about
Blondell
um I mean there's a lot more that could
be said about this but here's a
generalization you can kind of take to
the bank
Blondell would um
he would see what was going on with
two or more sides
that were being very polemical with each
other and often like losing the threat
of Truth and he'd say all right let's
you know we're not going to be like a
Centrist and just split the difference
all sidesism or any of that sort of
nonsense we're going to be really
rigorous and we're going to do
philosophy here we're going to see who's
full of crap and who's not and we're
going to apply some rigorous methods to
to critique this side and to cheat this
side and we're going to try to take
what's true in them and come up with a
better synthesis now when you do that
everybody hates you
right I mean that's almost inevitable
um I mean I found this out the hard way
when Facebook was was first becoming a
thing
um I was teaching critical thinking
classes and I'd have friends on right
and left you know from high school and
people would say uh you know crazy stuff
and then I'd be like well that's not
actually true and then they'd be like
you belong to that side we hate your
guts you know and then the same people
would do that on on the other side right
so Blondell is going to catch it from
everybody and I'm gonna simplify a
little bit some of the back and forth
arguments had to do with what was called
um modernism uh and modernism as
identified as a heresy by the Catholic
Church a belief that like religion needs
to be adapted to modern times in such a
way that it would lose a lot of what's
what's really Central to it right and
this was associated with like the higher
criticism and biblical studies which not
only applied to the Bible but also to
like stories about Saints you know the
Catholics were kind of at a real
disadvantage when it came to the higher
criticism
um and then you know so you got the
modernists on one side and there were
actual modernists Blondell was friends
with some of them
um they they were like yeah religion
needs to like totally reshape itself or
else it's it's not worth anything and
then there were the people that Blondell
called the veterans
um he also calls them
um
extrinsicists one word that he does use
that we now see coming on the fore
um integralists
there's there's a rise in uh religious
circles here in the United States and
elsewhere of integralism which says
basically the same sort of stuff that
oxio Frances was saying back in the
early 1900s and all the way to the 20s
until they got got condemned by the
Vatican if we're going too far
so blondella is trying to say that
listen we
we can't just
jump right down this sort of like
modernist everything's great because
it's modern get rid of all the old crap
kind of approach but we also can't be
these stick in the mud everything was
great under you know Saint Thomas
Aquinas the old church is the the best
thing
um we can't reject modernity
if Christianity is going to survive as
something other than you know a weird
aberration of itself it's got adapt it's
got to like rethink uh new situations
and that that's what he saw you know
um uh Leo the 13th doing
some Popes are more conservative Pius
the 10th
um was the one who condemned modernism
uh in his uh
thing and then the lamenta Billy Pius
the 10th also interestingly enough
because people started gunning for
Maurice Blondell Pius X actually
gave Blondell
you could say a shield he told one of
the most rabbit of the anti-modernists
um I assert that Blondell is orthodox
and you're not to go after him anymore
now that didn't keep some of the
Catholic figures from going after him
but so you've got all this stuff going
on right you got a lot of different
moving Parts here and Blondell
continually trying to thread this needle
you know of um you know I don't want to
be a modernist I also don't want to be a
veteranist I want to find something
better than that
um when it comes to social uh life I
don't want to be with the people who are
they weren't identified yet as fascists
but they're on the way to being fascists
axial front says and they're they're ilk
the anti-drafts but I also don't want to
um just you know give in to the the
forces on on the left either I want to
think this this stuff through I want to
think about what a just society would
look like what
um working people ought to have you know
how how these things ought to be
understood how old doctrines can be
brought into the the Modern Age to make
sense of this so he gets involved with
the cement social the social weak
movement which brings in all these great
experts for an entire week
um he actually gives a course uh one of
the things that I did translate and I
I may go back to it and fix it
um there's a piece called
and I think it's really really timely so
partly
Patria Homeland and we would translate
this as Homeland and Humanity
um Blondell saw the writing on the wall
about nationalism
and fascism and these movements that
were particularly again associated with
oxyon Francis in France
um by the way you know Steve Bannon when
he came on the scene I was like this guy
is just charl Moran uh Redux he's he's
not really doing anything new this is
very identifiable as what Blondell was
attacking
um so he he's he's talking about what a
just social order would look like and
what it would have to require and how we
would move forward so that's a lot of
what's going on in the 1900s for for
Blondell there's a couple other things I
mean his his wife his mother both die in
the same year which really sucks
um leaving him a with you know three
kids one of whom is a teenager
in the 1920s his site is actually going
to get really bad uh by 1927 he's
um
he's effectively working by dictation
um and he doesn't actually have a
secretary for a while who can
put together all of the documents that
he's got and all that it's amazing the
work that he did given that he was
nearly blind
um for it would be about
the second the two the last two decades
of his life
you know
um in the 1930s
again you know I've been clocking my
book again right so in the 1930s there
are these debates that are taking place
about Christian philosophy and they're
they're they're kicked off by the 1930
things that are being published because
1930 is the
um the 1500 year Centenary of the death
of Saint Augustine so Blondell writes a
couple pieces one of which is actually
just called I'll translate from the
French the uh 1500 year uh uh
anniversary of the death of Saint Saint
Augustine he also wrote another piece
called the uh forever or endlessly
renewed uh fertility of augustinian
thought he also writes another one the
latent resources of augustinian thought
and a lot of people are talking about
Augustine as being a Christian
philosopher and so people are like well
what what the hell does that actually
mean right what is Christian philosophy
it it some people so I've given you this
this hand out here it starts these
debates going on right in in
french-speaking areas and some people
are like there is no such thing as
Christian philosophy that's an oxymoron
if it's philosophy it can't have any
sort of religious Commitment if it's
Christianity it's not philosophical
um so there are these people called the
rationalists like Emil Brea young uh you
know sort of becoming very famous
historian of philosophy Leon bronchvig
who was uh blown on blownell's
dissertation committee
um he also thinks that this is a
mistaken idea
um you you also have some people from
the religious point of view who are like
yeah don't mix that philosophy crap in
with Christianity you're going to mess
it up
um Carl Bart would be an example of that
later on in Germany Leon schustoff
um he's an example of that and then
you've got some of the uh Neo
Scholastics or Neo Thomas who are also
saying this is a bad idea right
but there are some
um
other people mostly within Catholic but
also reformed Protestant circles who are
like no no there's there's something to
this we need to figure out what
Christian philosophy would look like and
the most interesting feature of these
debates is the rationalists were dealt
with really easily you know by the first
couple years they're they're like
knocked out of the debate
um the Neo Scholastics not paid that
much attention to the real battle is
between Catholic philosophers who think
that there is Christian philosophy but
how should you conceptualize this
and they don't agree and weirdly enough
and
um Jacques Martin are like the three
most important members Gabriel Marcel to
a lesser extent
and Jose Marth hen they line up against
Blondell and Blondell lines up against
them and a lot of other people take
stands and they all behave towards each
other as Catholic intellectuals who are
all decent people with an incredible
lack of Charity towards each other you
know like they're all misunderstanding
each other and fighting back and forth
um Blondell actually they all bring up
books uh she also has a whole bunch of
different books like the spirit of
medieval philosophy Blondell has this
book that he brings out the the problem
de la philosophy catalique in 1932 my
versions not in great shape so I won't
like pass it around you'll notice
there's like tape holding it together
and stuff
um
uh Mara tan brings out a book uh an
essay on Christian philosophy and then
there's these other people uh and you
notice some of them being listed there
Antonin certiage Henri de lubach uh
Bruno de Solange that are like listen
guys you're actually all on the same
page you're just talking past each other
um why can't you actually get along on
this matter and none of them actually
pay attention to that so there's an
incredible range of positions and this
is this is something it's a controversy
that from like 1931 to about 1935 1936
is just captivating the French
philosophical scene
um particularly if you have any
religious bent and um
it brings in a whole bunch of people and
then you know why does it uh Peter out
everybody's getting ready for war
World War II is gonna happen soon and
um Blondell is also moving on
he is going to produce a
[Music]
um metaphysical Trilogy it's called
and it's actually five volumes because
the first two the first book and the
last book are each two volumes so the
first book is called The Ponce thought
right and it's this incredibly detailed
study of what goes into human thinking
and he brings in this this idea of
cosmic thought
um the the second one is
being with a capital B and B yings right
and then Axion uh is the the third
um one two volumes again and it's a
redoing of oxygen 1893 like from the
ground up so he's working on that and
he's working on all sorts of other
things at the time as well I'll just
mention a few of them you know as the
war goes on and eventually
um you know France is occupied and then
you know the the Allies liberate France
um and World War II ends in 45 Blondell
has brought out a number of different uh
Works including I'll just translate the
it's in French
um battle for civilization and a
philosophy of Peace untranslated at this
time hard to get your hands on too
um by the very end of his life he's
written a few other things about social
matters but he's also
discussing existentialism which is now
coming on the scene
um he is
um
uh discussing some of the criticisms
that have been made of him but then
there's this
um
condition
meaning the conditions that would be
required for bringing about a worldwide
pacification of Peace bringing about
peace this is um
you know he views this as as quite
important
um
I mentioned that he would uh have
significant influence that would be the
Vatican too Vatican 2 is happening in
the 60s right blondell's long dead by
then so how does this guy wind up
influencing Vatican II to the point that
people would call him the philosopher of
Vatican II
well he influences two really important
strains of thought one is within uh the
Thomas tradition blondeletal it
influenced a lot of Thomas thinkers even
though he was not a Thomas and I should
say something about that too so one
tomeism was never the official Catholic
philosophy but it may as well have been
uh for quite a while even if you weren't
like super attracted to Thomas Aquinas
you would find it so much easier to get
your ideas listened to if you frame them
in terms of tomeism you could say from
like maybe well the the early 1900s all
the way into
the 60s
I think Vatican two kind of uh change
that a bit and so you've got all these
people who are using a Thomas vocabulary
to do philosophy and they're doing it
very different ways from each other
you've got like Thomas who think that
blondella is basically in League with
the devil like uh garagula garage who
even today people rely upon quite a bit
when somebody says oh yeah I'm into
garagu LaGrange I know they're like an
ultra conservative Catholic perhaps not
even in the church anymore because they
buy into like a schismatic thing
um because that was lagrange's uh stuff
um there's other people like uh Andre de
lubach who is a good friend of Maurice
Blondell very heavily influenced by him
Antonin
who unfortunately hasn't been translated
very much because his works are really
quite wonderful he had a guy who was
originally an opponent of him who comes
around to thinking that blondel is a
very important thinker Pierre Russo
Lowell
um Eve corjar Who's an important person
for the the Vatican Council even people
like Americans like Norris Clark are
influenced by Maurice blown Dell to some
degree so there are these Thomas that
are interested in Blondell and some of
them are what we call transcendental
tones
this gets kicked off with a guy Joseph
Marshal
who is a Jesuit who actually never never
gets to teach anything above college but
he writes all these great works and he
was really into blownell and then he
leads to Carl Rauner and then after them
calls comes Bernard Lonergan and all of
these people are trying to do kind of
what Blondell is doing we need to bring
Theology and and Christian philosophy
into the present we can't just pretend
like Emmanuel Kant doesn't matter or
pick whoever else you want we you know
we the way in which we show that that um
you know Christianity can adapt is we
take on the strongest the hardest
thought and we you know engage with it
fully and that's what the transcendental
Thomas are doing there's also this
movement called the nouvell theology new
Theology and um Andre de Lubeck would be
a great example of that
um that's heavily influenced by Maurice
Blondell among some other thinkers like
Charles Peggy who unfortunately dies in
World War one uh and and some others as
well and then there's you could also say
there's a third thing that's not
affecting Vatican 2 quite so much but
it's going to play a role later on and
that is the phenomenological movement
what blondella's doing is not in
phenomenology but it's very similar to
it
instead of calling his work
phenomenology he calls it first the
method of imminence and then he calls it
the method of implication but it's quite
similar and Blondell paved the way for
phenomenology to come into France
he also got read by people like Carol
voltia in the Lublin Thomas Carol votea
would become John Paul II
John Paul II would write a uh encyclical
while I was in graduate school we all
you know read it and discussed it called
fide razio faith and reason and if you
read that document you're going to see
like a whole laundry list of like
philosophers that we ought to be looking
at some of whom are Thomas some of whom
aren't like Dietrich Von hildenbrand or
Gabriel Marcel and as I think it was
fiakra long pointed out you're not going
to see blondell's name in the document
because the whole document could be by
Blondell
that entire like this is the definitive
Catholic take on what faith and reason
should look like going into the New
Millennium is Thoroughly blown alien
because John John Paul II new blondell's
work and was was uh clearly influenced
by it in his approaches so you know
Blondell continues to exercise some
interesting behind the scenes
significance but not a lot of people are
reading them these days there is there
is a um
Blondell archives in luvanna and they
put on conferences every once in a while
but it's is if we look at who's doing
the conference this is all like the same
old Scholars you know it's not not a
great sign for you know longevity of
blown now studies when you don't have a
ton of young people studying it right
you need new blood
but um you know he could he could have a
Revival people like me uh could come
along and be told by their mentors you
should read this guy and then start
reading him and then be like holy crap
this stuff is really quite extraordinary
um who knows we don't really know what's
going to happen
um I might translate some some Blondell
stuff there's a few other people
interested in it but translation is a
lot of work you know so I don't know if
I if I want to do the work or not
um but he's he's a very interesting guy
um you know part of the theme of this
this series is how these philosophers
contributed to history
um blown Dell contributed not just to
the history of philosophy but changes
within uh the Catholic Church
um and you could say you know there's a
lot of like bad changes that happen
within the Catholic Church you say
Blondell is not responsible unless
you're unless you're one of those like
super ultra Conservative Catholics in
which case blown down you blame for
everything uh without ever reading them
um Blondell is largely responsible for a
lot of good changes within the church
and he's not really tied in with the bad
changes you know
um like you know for example this will
this will be a little bit of a
controversial thing you know the
Catholic church is within the middle of
a sexual harass a sexual abuse Scandal
that just never seems to end right and
lots more still needs to be done in
order to to fix things and provide
Justice to you know those who were
abused
um and it led to a lot of secularization
where people are like the church doesn't
doesn't defend people you know except
for the bad guys if Blondell were around
he would be super involved in criticism
of that you know
um that's the kind of kind of person
that he he was
um he'd probably be so involved that
he'd get himself in some trouble you
know with some of the uh the theologians
or Bishops he certainly would be
condemning Catholic integralism which is
a growing movement right now
um tied in with you know conception
totalitarian conceptions around the
world I think it's a dangerous movement
Blondell is a serious critic of that so
maybe we uh we need to bring him more
back on the scene
um he's certainly a polarizing figure
um
and that's that's pretty much all that I
have to say about about him usually we
like take a little pause in the middle
for Q a but I I thanks for like bearing
with me on this but let's you know let's
do some discussion or questions and
answer at this point because I don't
have much more
uh plan to say I mean there's tons and
tons of stuff that I could say but which
things should I should I focus on that's
that's the hard thing for a guy who
lived so long wrote so much and made so
many interesting contributions so what
um what would you like to talk about
well what can can you talk a little bit
more about his actual methodology I
tried to read a little bit about it yeah
so I mentioned that
um
he he calls what he's doing by two
different names right
the method of imminence
is basically you you could think about
it as like give philosophies enough rope
to hang themselves right so if you want
to if you want to really grapple with
modern thought
um you think it through all the ways see
what's really there what it would be
like to live a life like Descartes or
Spinoza or Hagel or pick whoever you
want what would be the total
implications of their thought
um
you you sort of like um
it it you another way of thinking about
it is you give them complete charity but
then you're critical
and
um how is it like hagel's thought well
Hegel thinks that one of the things that
you have to do is
um
you you don't just take something for
granted as what it is you study it and
see what it develops into so you know
for example when we're thinking about
the choices that we make or let's make
it even bigger like we're doing
something as a society
um there are always going to be
oversimplifications that we're relying
upon when we make decisions about let's
do this thing right and we don't just
like we shouldn't just like wait around
and see what happens
we should think out the implications
ahead of time you know this would lead
to this well maybe we don't take this
route then or we start seeing where the
hidden contradictions and things are and
seeing whether they're real
contradictions like there this is an
impasse you want to believe this and
believe this but you can't believe both
together
or whether they call for us to like
rethink how we conceptualize this and
conceptualize this and
that's essentially what the method of
imminence is doing
um the word imminence tended to get him
in trouble
in part because some of the modernists
also like that word a lot you know
imminence is usually compared to
Transcendence right so instead of having
some like bring things in from above and
impose the structures there you look and
see what's actually there so you know
for example in oxio 1893 right it begins
um when you look at the table of
contents it begins by looking at um
is there a problem of action is is there
really well actually I should read this
line because it's a beautiful uh
beginning that he has let me get past
the introduction here
um
he says yes or no does human life make
sense
and does man have a destiny I act but
without even knowing what action is
without having wished to live without
knowing exactly exactly either who I am
or even if I am the superior appearance
of being which flutters about within me
these light and effanescent actions of a
shadow bearing them I am told an
eternally weighty responsibility and uh
that even at the price of blood I cannot
buy nothingness because it is for me no
longer supposedly then I am condemned to
life condemned to death condemned to
Eternity why and by what right if I did
not know it and did not will it and he
says well there's a problem here he says
this problem is inevitable we resolve it
inevitably and the solution true or
false each one bears in his actions this
is why we must study action so what does
he do then he actually studies
how does the will work how do people
human beings make commitments and
decisions which ones are going the right
way which ones are going the wrong way
so again to go like the question you
asked about Hegel hegel's doing
something kind of similar except he's
doing it you know
not quite a hundred years before but 80
90 years before and Blondell is doing it
from you could say different Vantage
points
um Hegel is pretty abstract compared to
Blondell you know
um neither of them are the clearest of
writers
I'll say that
um Buffalo Dale's probably clearer than
Hegel at least but he you know he is
similar to Hegel in that you don't just
do like separate analyzes of each thing
you want them to like join together in
something like a system that you could
you could understand and the other thing
that um we're blown down in Hegel are
both
they're both grappling with the same
thing but they're going to take
different solutions
so you know when we look at philosophy
throughout its history
and we get away from like contemporary
analytic philosophy or some of the you
know what we often call Continental
philosophy where the focus is much more
narrow and the the view is like
philosophy can't do much of anything you
know just little bits and pieces here
philosophy has typically been understood
as like being about the whole of reality
right it's we want to have a rational
approach to as much as we can so
philosophy is making some big big claims
what does religion do while religion is
kind of like philosophy in that
um I mean you can just like focus on I
just go to church and you know say my
prayers and I don't think about all
these sort of things but that's not what
um what particular religious Traditions
do they have like a you know everything
is covered right so they're gonna come
in conflict
pretty soon
because they're both making claims about
the whole and all the different things
within it so the question is can they do
they have to be opposed to each other or
can they interfuse in some way or is one
subordinated to the other
interestingly too
um
well before I say this thing so Hegel
his view as well philosophy trumps
religion religion is for you know
religion is representation it's for
people who aren't smart enough to get
philosophy
um and and the way that you make
religion better is you turn it into
philosophy
Blondell wants to hold on to both of
them he doesn't want he doesn't want to
throw away philosophy
and say well you know
religion will give us everything no
philosophy has a role to play and he
sees like in the history of Christianity
that it has played an incredibly
important role Augustine was not just a
theologian he was a philosopher Thomas
Aquinas was a philosopher right
um Pascal was a philosopher even though
they all had religious orientations so
somehow you got to get those two big
colossal
cultural intellectual forces to not be
at each other's throat all the time and
that's that's what Blondell is trying to
do right but he realizes that you can't
like
you can make a case for that but you
can't like make everybody get along
um the other thing I'll say too is that
the stuff that Blondell is saying and
the stuff that Hagel is saying about you
know in terms of religion and philosophy
it's not just a Christianity problem
it's also a problem for Islam it's also
a problem for Hinduism it's also a
problem for for Buddhism uh particularly
theistic Buddhism you know which is the
majority worldwide of you know
practicing Buddhists
um they have some sort of beliefs about
you know a cosmic Buddha or
you know gods and bodhisattvas and
things doing doing particular tasks
um how do you line up a vast religious
tradition with what philosophy and also
what modern thought are are contributing
Blondell doesn't worry about that he's
he's got enough to do with Christianity
and the complicated Church politics of
his time but the implications are are
considerably wider
um
I think they could apply to really any
religion
that wants to
be plausible in our modern era but also
has these sort of like global
sets of claims you know upon us I I mean
I've ranged kind of far from your
original question but does that help at
all they're both kind of iterative that
I'm gonna yeah yeah very much you know
you work on you work on it and you
you you yeah you find something but you
find some problems and you kind of got
to go to a another level and then you
gotta work from that level or you solve
but you then you have a problem that's
right yeah and you keep going on these
levels right yeah you know um I forget
who used this metaphor and it's being
used for Hegel and for Blondell they
call it um cycloidal right so it's not
just
um like an endless Circle you actually
do make some progress but you don't make
it in a linear fashion you make it by
slowly spiraling in and getting closer
at least you think I mean maybe what
ends up happening is uh you get about to
this point and then suddenly it gets big
again and you're like oh gotta do some
more circling around right
um but you're right yeah well both Hegel
and Blondell are doing that and it's
because philosophy as like you could
call it the premier work of the human
mind and religion this orientation
towards whatever we consider to be
divine they're incredibly complicated
right and they're mediated through other
people none of us come to philosophy
I mean so like think about Renee
Descartes right so Renee Descartes is
going to like do Philosophy from the
ground up he's got his um stove heated
famous stove heated room now he can
finally think to himself because it's
winter nobody's going to bug him now
I'll like clear everything away and
start a new right
you can imagine that you're starting
from from you know brand new but
Descartes smuggles in all this stuff as
Scholars have shown from earlier
philosophy that he he buys into you know
and he he of course engages with other
philosophers like Thomas Hobbes you know
Pierre gasendi who's an Epicurean writes
writes some of the objections and he
responds to those so nobody's like
beginning from scratch we're always like
beginning
in the middle of a conversation that's
been going on for for a long time in in
philosophy and I would say the same
thing for religion right it's not like
we let's say you want to convert and
join some religious group well they've
already got a bunch of ideas and a bunch
of practices and a whole bunch of you
know explanations of what they're doing
and you gotta you gotta kind of work
your way into it I mean one of the
interesting things that we could ask is
is there anything else like that besides
philosophy and
religion that has that that scope right
maybe in modernity you know
um
but Blondell doesn't seem to think so he
seems to think that those those two are
like the biggest cultural forces that we
need to make sense out of
so
yeah any other questions or
about this guy yeah good to see you
you're gonna take off all right I'll see
you later
so so
you're
what I tried to read is yeah you you
kind of look at things I'll say
in as they are in the real world and
you do what you can but then you you get
to the point where you you you you find
problems or you you find your problems
you know your your obstacles yeah your
contradictions the Transcendence you go
to a
but then it's like a loop though so
you're at a higher level but you're
still working on stuff how does Blondell
I mean ever get you to the to the you
know I'll say the beam with the capital
B you know oh because if you're
constantly going yeah you're never gonna
in theory you're never going to get to
that ultimate State well I mean you
don't have to get to an ultimate State
um for for Blondell
um it's enough to like figure out where
you fit in as a being that acts that
thinks that that is
um and if there is like an ultimate
State I mean for Blondell that would be
that would be God the supernatural the
ultimately Transcendent
um and and you're not going to become
God or fully understand God I mean even
Thomas Aquinas doesn't think that we we
ever comprehend God
um even the blessed in heaven God
according to Thomas but that doesn't
mean that you can't like distinguish
different different legitimately
connected levels you know
um like you know for example one of the
one of the tricky things in social
theory whether it's Hagel or blownell or
whoever else is how do you how do you
recognize that
um
society and our political Community is
something bigger than all of us and
shouldn't be just subordinated to a
whole bunch of you know individuals
um and also maintain scope
for you know like the Dignity of the
human person right that's tough to pull
off
um because if you you know you push more
towards like the society is what matters
uh eventually you get to some sort of
totalitarianism right if you push too
far over to the individualistic side
then you get like either like you know
complete chaos or some Elite capturing
the society and it's not really about
all individuals it's about what's good
for those individuals and
um how do you how do you recognize the
fact that we are
social creatures and we also are centers
of
plans and desires and agency that are
legitimate you know
um that's part of what he's trying to
hagel's trying to figure that out too
blondel's trying to figure that out and
lots of other
um thinkers you could say are also
trying to figure out that puzzle and
that could be like a strata Within
the system that you're you're working at
you know
I mean it winds up having so many moving
parts
that I don't know you could even like
graphically represent it
you know whether it's Hagel or Blondell
I tried
to take hegel's phenomenology
and I took like some big
um paper from like you know when I was
working with uh oil pastels I had this
giant like reams of paper and I use
really really small writing and I tried
to map out for myself all the different
things going on in hegel's phenomenology
and I still have it somewhere in a box
yeah I mean the main reason why I did
that was because I was told I had to
when I so I had to take a special
thinker exam right and this is when I
was working on my dissertation so I took
hegel's my special thinker and I asked
the guy who's in charge what should I
study he said
I just memorized all the dialectics and
the phenomenology and then read a little
bit of the science of logic and I was
like
how do you do that you know and so I was
like well I've got to put it into
graphic form of some sort and and but
what I did was very schematic you know
it doesn't adequately capture
the thought involved in that it's it's
just a representation right to use
hegel's term and I think you can do a
similar thing with oxy in 1993 or blow I
mean nobody's done that with the
metaphysical Trilogy these five volumes
that are like 2 000 pages that are still
in French you know
um
I I don't know how you would do that
there are a lot of moving parts and the
trick is to see how these parts kind of
fit into each other then again you know
think about Legos people get kits that
are like 10 000 pieces and they put them
together you know
so you know maybe maybe we could do that
with Legos maybe we could do that with
thought I don't know
uh but it would be it'd be quite a
challenge I mean we're much better when
we're like focused on a problem right
then all of the problems at once and and
this is a bit of a side note but
sometimes when we're looking at these
very systematic thinkers and it could be
lonel or Hagel or it could be
schopenhauer's world as well and
representation or a manual kant's uh
critique of pure reason or any very con
or starts being a nothing it's any very
complicated philosophical work
um we're reading it and we sometimes get
dismayed because we're like holy crap is
this complicated how the hell did they
think these thoughts right and and we're
comparing where we are at this moment in
time to what took years to produce
Blondell didn't think all these thoughts
at one time or even in one week he
thought them over a long period and then
he joined them together right so when
we're looking at a systematic work of
philosophy or I think this could even
apply to like you know you think about
um a great novel right a great novel is
not written in one week
all this stuff required a whole bunch of
thinking and work and and bringing it
together and it may it may not even be
the case that Blondell ever in his life
had all the thoughts that he articulated
here like arranged in his mind any more
than Hegel with the phenomenology Spirit
right
um
I don't know what to make of I don't
know what to do with that thought but I
think it could be
it could be helpful for people who feel
dismayed because
um Things Are
you know read a really great work and
you're like
I'd never be able to write something
like that or think something like that
well you don't have to because they
didn't either
you know they just stuck with it longer
and we're lucky that life didn't screw
them up so that they couldn't follow us
yeah exactly I mean it's easier to do
stuff like this
when you're in graduate school or or you
know you've got a nice teaching position
somewhere
um
then if you're working two jobs and
you know I mean start just to go back to
him he would walk around with the
equivalent of like you know a thousand
bucks in his pocket he was not hurting
for
you know anything he was from a
Bourgeois family he would he was you
know
he was okay he could he could work on
being in nothingness all he wanted so
um I mean it's it
somebody would be in contrast that would
be like
um Franz Kafka
who is you know working in an insurance
company and writing his writings at
Night by himself right is like a
sideline
so any other questions or
well thanks so much for your attention
and I hope you you know
um check out Blondell sometime he's uh
worthwhile author
um I don't know who we're doing yet next
year what we usually do is
um February May August November first
Wednesday of the month unless there's
some sort of conflict and so I have to
think about who I want to do for ancient
that I haven't done already
um then medieval I think we'll probably
do Bonaventure for medieval because
we're supposed to do him but then I got
I had coven that's right I I had coveted
in May so I couldn't come here to to
give the talk and then there's plenty of
modern thinkers for us to to figure out
so I guess I just have to figure out who
the ancient thinker is going to be for
next time because I've already done
Plato Aristotle
Cicero Plutarch
Epictetus
epicurus I think I did
so maybe Seneca you know maybe maybe
somebody else
but thanks so much for uh for coming and
uh hopefully I'll see you next time